[Musique]
ou beaucoup payent tout en la parole
n'importe quoi s'agit-il tout le temps
la même chose c'est parce que vous ne
comprenez pas ce que je raconte
l'as roma
qui c'était c'était et bientôt mon
chambre alors j'arrête de temps d'aller
et on rentre oui comme à chaque fois
qu'une de ses filles à un amoureux que
jamais il se présenta pas vu comment ils
bavent devant la télé à chaque fois
qu'ils ne le voit si jamais ils le
rencontrent dans le président regarde
regarde qu'ils aient croisette
totalement par hasard il est génial ce
mec je n'avais jamais vécu ça à moi pour
la dernière fois ce n'est pas ton petit
copain c'est le petit copain de ta fille
qu'est ce qui s'passe nouveau marquée en
belgique un truc tout entre nous car on
voulait qu'on était connecté maintenant
je parle t rex et moi on peut pas rompre
et quelqu'un qui fait moins de onze
seront 200 m abbey avait pas que vous
semble qu'ils aient moins d une seconde
si tu veux savoir plus au sud oui
d'ailleurs là mon grand père qui est là
pour être encore dit pourquoi on regarde
le c'est un dieu dans un corps d'enfant
je suis super bowl tu as pensé à lui
envoyer un cadeau de la part de tomates
non
qu'est ce que c'est que ça oh ça ne rend
pas malheureux de voir à quel point tu
es frustré d'avoir eu que des filles
à temps
c'est ce que je vois c'est quelqu'un a
brisé le coeur ouais tu es
une porte à coups de grâce